hello there my name is aaron mckie but  on YouTube people refer to me as a  Vulcan and I am a wannabe voice actor  from Northern Ireland my youtube channel  is dedicated to my voiceover work my  most common projects are SCP related but  I also tend to recreate speeches or  monologues  that I love from movies or games or or  anything else just anything that allows  me to express myself in vocal form oh  one more thing I encourage people to  sent me requests you can visit  facebook.com forward slash the volgen  you can ask me on Twitter  zennith strife or email me at vo aaron  mckie korra UK all details will be in  the video description I really hope you  enjoy the content I produce thank you  you